[Applause]
hi everyone I'm Jana I'm a data
scientist at Selden and mostly for my
interest who's come across multi-on
bandits in the data science journey okay
a lot of people actually okay that's
good
so there's many ways you can think about
Multi unbounded problems one way I want
to introduce it is as a almost like an
extension to a/b testing so so what's a
multi-armed bandit problem so it's a
decision problem you had you as a
decision maker have a number of discrete
choices to make and you have some number
of trials which is typically unknown can
be infinite usually is and at each of
those trials you pick exactly one choice
called an action a and you get a reward
that's associated to that particular
action that you took and the reward
comes from some reward distribution
that's specific to that to the action
that you chose so now you want to use
that information to maximize your total
expected reward so how can you do that
you need some kind of performance
measure simplest one is you just as you
keep doing your trials you keep keep
track of your sample average for each of
your choices and then you somehow need
to use that information to pick the best
possible action at each time step the
easiest thing you can think of you can
just always take the pick the arm that
has currently the highest sample average
so far you can probably see that this is
not very good because you might get
lucky on your first trial get a good
reward for from a distribution that's AK
whose mean is actually quite bad and but
then you're forever stuck with the
worst-performing
action so there's quite a lot of
research about this there is an exact
solution cause called Gittens indices
but they're only applied to some in some
certain reward distribution cases so one
point I wanted to share with you today I
came across in my research it was about
multi imbalance in the world war in
World War two the problem is a classic
one it was formulated during the war
efforts to saw its source at the
energies and minds of
analyst that the suggestion was made
that the problem be drops over Germany
as the ultimate instrument of
intellectual sabotage and so you can
imagine how I feel so there's there's
lots of approximate solution methods
that do very well and various kinds of
reward distributions and that are used
in practice successfully and you can
think of a/b testing as one of them in
the multi unbanded literature is
something that's called this epsilon
first strategy where you have a certain
time period where you first explore all
the possible options uniformly at random
to gather evidence and then at some
point you decide okay this is my best
possible choice I will forever exploit
this one and that's basically what I'd
be testing does slightly more
sophisticated choice you can have
epsilon greedy methods where you always
choose the best action at this
particular time but a small amount of
time epsilon you explore random of
opportunities so this make sure that you
don't get stuck you know in a suboptimal
arm slightly better so there's some some
more advanced techniques by the way all
these are very easily implementable in
Python or in any language upper
confidence bound it's also called
optimism in the face of uncertainty
basically it says oK we've haven't
explored these arms quite sufficiently
yet so we don't know what our estimates
are so we might want to sample these a
bit more that kind of stuff
last one Thompson sampling is my
favorite one because it's Bayesian you
have a you start with a prior over the
arms and after each trial you get an
updated posterior and then you sample
from the posterior to pick your choices
it's quite nice work to in practice so
I'm not just making this up the a very
simple experiment if you have two arms
the newly distributed rewards so zeros
and ones one arm has 50% chance of
giving you one the other one has a 60%
chance so you can think of this as some
sort of conversion rate for example 50
percent that's quite high and 60 percent
is something you might not observe but
we do observe if we simulate it so you
can run experiments with different
strategies so for a/b testing I
mm trials until deciding I was going to
go with the with the winning one and I
got reasonably lucky to choose the
winning one but I left quite a lot of
conversion on the table and all the
other methods that I mentioned converge
much quicker through the optimal method
so there's lots of extensions you can do
these you can have a non-stationary
rewards contextual bandits is very
interesting because you might what you
might have some additional information
using features if you're serving
websites your your user features might
be important that's it
[Applause]